for weeks the undisputed hot movie topic
has been the inaugural trailer for
legendary pictures godzilla vs kong
on january 24 2021 avid monsterverse
devotees and novice kaiju fans alike got
their first glimpse of the titular beast
doing battle taking the internet by
storm in short order
everyone began tossing out their
theories predictions and even bets as to
which way this fight of the century is
going to go
however they'll be waiting just a bit
longer to get the definitive answer as
the feature won't hit big screens in hbo
max until march 31st
we need kong the world needs him
in the meantime eager moviegoers and
streamers have resorted to looking back
upon the rich cinematic histories of
both kong and godzilla
king kong entered pop culture in 1933
and godzilla
in 1954 both franchises have dozens of
films and tv shows to watch today
from every era and with every budget you
can imagine but you could be forgiven
for opting to watch only the best of the
best from recent years
other fans are apparently making the
same choice this has caused two fan
favorite monster movies to rise for
netflix viewers in south and central
america as of late
if you happen to live elsewhere never
fear these monster movies loom large and
are available from multiple other
sources
first is 2014's godzilla reboot directed
by gareth edwards of rogue one of star
wars story fame
this was the 30th godzilla-centric
feature in its multi-generational
history and it kicked off legendary
picture shared universe with a battle
featuring the titular reptile and a pair
of mutos
massive unidentified terrestrial
organisms as of this video it holds a 76
certified fresh score on rotten tomatoes
with critics praising it for its sense
of scale and the story's balance between
the destructive monsters and hapless
humans caught in the crossfire
additionally fans are also brushing up
on their calling knowledge with the
re-watch of 2017's kong skull island
director jordan vogt roberts's film is
actually the first monsterverse
installment
chronologically speaking and brings
audiences back to the 1970s
in the wake of the vietnam war a small
expedition sails to the mysterious skull
island to investigate what may be
lurking in its jungles swamps and
mountains
lost and cut off from the outside world
they encounter the mighty kong and work
alongside him to escape to the refuge of
civilization once again
it falls just short of godzilla's rotten
tomato score fetching a certified fresh
75 percent and wowing critics with its
solid performances and bold departure
from previous king kong movies
not ready to dive into the monsterverse
just yet but still need to scratch that
kaiju itch
no problem because netflix has a handful
of other offerings relating to both kong
and godzilla
in the case of kong there's the netflix
original kong king of the apes
released in 2016 this show depicts the
titular primate working together with a
team of kids to stop robot dinosaurs
from taking over the world this animated
series is perfect for younger audiences
who may not be prepared for the more
mature kong skull island or for those
interested in the character but wanting
something lighter to watch
its only two seasons are currently
available for streaming so you ready for
another round
all right alternatively if you're
committed to team godzilla or just have
a hankering for some good anime
netflix has the perfect trilogy for you
the first installment came out in 2017
titled godzilla planet to the monsters
and was followed by both godzilla city
on the edge of battle and godzilla the
planet eater in 2018. the films follow a
small group of people 20 000 years in
the future and king ghidorah features
prominently as well
this is only the tip of the iceberg when
it comes to kong and godzilla medium but
if you just want to catch up with the
best of the recent installments before
godzilla vs kong launches
these are your best bets check out one
of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite monster movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one